Olá tudo bem Aqui o Dr Alan Machado
Dutra médico há mais de 25 anos e hoje
eu vou falar sobre o magnésio você já
deve estar familiarizados com alguns dos
benefícios do magnésio mas nesse vídeo
Vamos explorar descobertas mais recentes
da ciência que nos mostram como
experimentar esse mineral e como pode
ser fundamental nos dias de hoje eu vou
focar especialmente como o magnésio pode
ser um aliado poderoso na prevenção do
infarto e do acidente vascular cerebral
a AVC além de ajudar na redução das suas
sequelas mas não para por aí estudos
recentes TM destacado também o papel do
magnésio na saúde cerebral mostrando
como ele pode ajudar a retardar o
processo de envelhecimento mental É
incrível como a ingestão regular desse
mineral está associada à proteção
cerebral especialmente nas mulheres
então vocês devem estar se perguntando
Mas será que todo mundo precisa
suplementar
a resposta a essa pergunta Depende muito
da sua alimentação e estilo de vida mas
deixe-me compartilhar alguns dados
impactantes que mostram porque a maioria
das pessoas realmente deveria considerar
a suplementação de magnésio talvez até
mesmo de forma contínua Vamos considerar
um fato alarmante mais de 66% da
população não atinge nem a quantidade
mínima recomendada de magnésio na
alimentação
e se olharmos para as últimas cinco
décadas notaremos um declínio nos níveis
desse mineral essencial começando com a
degradação do solo especificamente aqui
no Brasil nosso solo não é proveniente
de atividades vulcânicas e tem poucas
áreas de solos ultram máficos que são os
dois tipos mais ricos em magnésio O que
significa que naturalmente O Brasil
possui menos magnésio no solo Além disso
mesmo que consumamos alimentos
naturalmente ricos em magnésio o
processo de fabricação quando são
refinados e processados os alimentos
resulta em uma perda significativa desse
mineral chegando a 80% do conteúdo
original Isso significa que mesmo os
alimentos que seriam boas fontes de
magnésio perdem grande parte de seu
valor nutricional antes mesmo de
chegarem ao nosso prato se sua dieta
inclui uma grande variedade de alimentos
ricos em magnésio como é o caso de
verduras folhosas sementes de abóbora
amêndoas abacate sementes de gergelim em
linhaça entre outros você pode até estar
bem suprido de magnésio no entanto se
sua alimentação inclui produtos
processados como farinhas e grãos
refinados a probabilidade de você ser
deficiente em magnésio é bem alta nesse
caso a suplementação desse mineral não é
apenas recomendada é essencial como
médico sempre destaco a importância
desse mineral que trabalha em equipe em
conjunto com outros nutrientes para
manter nosso corpo em pleno
funcionamento por exemplo o magnésio é
vital paraa produção de ATP a principal
fonte de energia na nossas células e não
é só isso ele também é essencial para a
saúde dos Ossos não basta apenas
consumir cálcio para fortalecer os ossos
o magnésio é indispensável
porque ajuda na absorção de cálcio e na
formação óssea Além disso o magnésio é
um grande aliado da Saúde cardiovascular
regulando o ritmo cardíaco e a pressão
arterial ele também é essencial para a
contração e relaxamento dos músculos
prevenindo câimbras e também desempenha
um papel fundamental no sistema nervoso
central e periférico magnésio ajuda a
reduzir o stresse e ansiedade acalmando
o sistema nervoso sendo mineral
importante no tratamento desses
problemas e na melhoria da qualidade do
Sono sabiam que muitas pessoas que
sofrem de insônia podem se beneficiar do
uso do magnésio especialmente as
mulheres ele também pode aliviar
sintomas da TPM como cólicas menstruais
e ajudar a amenizar os sintomas da
menopausa Mas agora você deve estar
pensando nos diferentes tipos de
magnésio que estão disponíveis E qual
seria o mais adequado para você certo
primeiro recomendo que assistam ao meu
vídeo anterior tipos de magnésio para
cada problema Esse vídeo é específico é
top para quem está enfrentando sintomas
ou condições de saúde específicas e quer
entender melhor qual é o tipo de
magnésio mais dicado mais benéfico para
cada caso eu vou deixar o link desse
vídeo na descrição e também num Card
aqui acima Mas no geral pessoal quanto a
suplementação é importante de escolher
um produto que seja adequado para você e
que caiba no seu bolso no seu orçamento
um estudo indicou que o citrato e o
glicinato de magnésio são melhor
absorvidos do que o óxido e o Sulfato de
Magnésio já O cloreto de magnésio não é
o melhor em termos de absorção mas se é
o que cabe no seu orçamento é mais
importante utilizar do que não usar nada
por outro lado o magnésio glicina malato
e o treonato são consideradas opções
melhores sendo magnésio treonato
particularmente recomendado paraa saúde
cerebral em termos de dosagem uma
quantidade razoável pra maioria das
pessoas é cerca de 200 a 400 mg de
magnésio por dia a menos que o seu
médico lhe diga o contrário te Oriente
de outra forma é melhor tomar cerca de
200 a 400 mg por dia no máximo no
entanto dependendo das necessidades
individuais algumas pessoas podem podem
precisar de doses maiores até 600 MG por
dia isso deve ser avaliado de forma
individual para entender a necessidade
específica de cada um de nós e se você
for suplementar quando deve tomar o
magnésio a melhor hora do dia pra
maioria das pessoas é antes de dormir
também é uma boa ideia dividir as doses
tomando uma de manhã e outra à noite O
que pode ajudar na absorção agora vamos
falar sobre um equívoco comum você fez
um exame de sangue e seus níveis de
magnésio apareceram como normais Então
você pensa que está tudo bem certo bom
pessoal não é bem assim diferente de
outros minerais como o cálcio e o sódio
que são facilmente medidos nos fluídos
fora das células o magnésio é um mineral
predominantemente intracelular é o caso
também do
potássio ou seja eles Residem dentro das
células Isso significa que um exame de
sangue comum pode não detectar uma
deficiência de magnésio porque ela
começa dentro das células e não se
mostra facilmente no tecido extracelular
ela não mostra facilmente o que está
acontecendo dentro das células o
magnésio é importante para muitas
funções celulares incluindo o controle
dos canais de sódio potássio e de cálcio
por isso para realmente avaliar se você
tem uma quantidade adequada de magnésio
o ideal seria fazer um exame chamado
magnésio intracelular
ou intra eritrocitário esse exame mostra
a quantidade de magnésio dentro das
células oferecendo uma visão mais
precisa do que tá acontecendo se tá
faltando ou não sobre os seus níveis
reais e não se Surpreenda muitas pessoas
que fazem esse exame específico
descobrem que estão de fato com
deficiência de magnésio então mesmo que
os seus exames de sangue pareçam normais
é importante Estar atento aos sinais que
seu corpo pode estar dando que est
precisando desse mineral e conversar com
o seu médico sobre a possibilidade de
suplementar sobre a possibilidade de uma
deficiência desse mineral talvez você
não saiba mas a falta do magnésio pode
se manifestar de várias formas algumas
delas bem sérias por exemplo batimentos
cardíacos irregulares ou acelerados são
sintomas clássicos da falta de Magnésio
e você pode sentir dormência ao
formigamento nas mãos e pés além de
câimbras musculares não só na as pernas
mas em outras partes do corpo também
outro sinal comum é a dificuldade para
dormir sim problemas para pegar no sono
podem estar ligados à falta de Magnésio
e tem mais intestino preso dores
musculares e até condições mais
complicadas como fibromialgia que causa
dor e sensibilidade em várias partes do
corpo também tem relação com a falta
desse mineral a ansiedade a pressão alta
o cansaço constante enxaquecas severas e
até osteoporose
podem ser sinais de que você não está
recebendo magnésio de forma suficiente
então se você está lidando com alguns
desses sintomas pode ser uma boa ideia
pensar em incluir magnésio não apenas
como suplemento mas como algo essencial
para manter o equilíbrio e saúde do seu
corpo pessoal vamos falar de saúde
cardiovascular recentes estudos têm
evidenciado ainda mais a importância
Vital do magnésio para a saúde do
sistema cardiovascular uma revisão de
2018 revelou que uma deficiência
subclínica de magnésio pode aumentar o
risco de várias doenças cardiovasculares
como doença arterial coronariana e a
pressão alta a hipertensão então manter
níveis adequados de magnésio é o fator
chave pra prevenção de problemas
cardíacos a hipertensão ou pressão alta
é uma condição que afeta muita gente
Milhão de pessoas a redor do mundo ela
exige que o coração trabalhe mais do que
a normal o que pode levar ao desgaste do
músculo cardíaco e aumentar o risco de
doenças cardíacas e estudos recentes
mostram que a suplementação com magnésio
pode reduzir de forma significativa a
pressão arterial em adultos que já t o
diagnóstico de hipertensão Além disso o
magnésio ajuda a controlar as bombas nas
células que regulam a entrada e saída de
cálcio potásio essas bombas são
essenciais para manter o ritmo cardíaco
regular e prevenir arritmias quando há
deficiência de magnésio essas bombas não
funcionam de forma adequada levando a um
desequilíbrio que pode resultar em
sérios problemas cardíacos ah e não
posso esquecer de mencionar que além do
magnésio o potássio também desempenha um
papel importante na saúde
cardiovascular ele ajuda a regular a
pressão arterial aumentando a excreção
de sódio pelo urina o que alivia a carga
sobre o coração essa regulação da
pressão arterial não só é importante na
prevenção de doenças cardíacas mas
também na redução do risco de acidente
vascular cerebral o famoso
AVC estudos recentes têm destacado essa
importância uma análise de diversos
estudos controlados e randomizados com
Placebo revelou que uma dose média
diária de 368 MG de magnésio ao longo de
cerca de 3 meses pode diminuir a pressão
arterial oferecendo uma proteção
substancial contra o desenvolvimento de
AVC outro estudo mostrou que cada
aumento de 100 mg na ingestão de área de
magnésio está associado a uma redução de
88% no risco de AVC enfatizando a
importância de uma dieta rica em
magnésio para prevenir essa condição
grave e algo interessante a notar é que
alguns estudos indicam que mulheres com
baixos níveis desse mineral tem um risco
de 57 7% maior de sofrer um AVC
isquêmico Além disso níveis mais
elevados de magnésio na admissão
hospitalar estão ligados a um volume
menor de hemorragia cerebral pontuações
menos graves em casos de hemorragia
intracerebral espontânea e até mesmo a
uma redução na mortalidade e sobre o
magnésio e a saúde cerebral bem os
estudos sobre a forma de magnésio
treonato oferecem perspectivas
animadoras sobre o seu impacto no
cérebro essa fórmula combina o magnésio
com Lonato um ácido derivado da vitamina
C que facilita a entrada do magnésio no
sistema nervoso onde promove a
reconstrução de conexões neuronais e
potencializa a neuroplasticidade
cerebral com essa habilidade esse tipo
de magnésio é um agente promissor para
melhorar a função cognitiva o
aprendizado e a memória Olha que
interessante pessoal uma pesquisa
significativa Public no jornal of
alheimer disease observou melhorias
notáveis na função executiva e na
memória de trabalho após apenas seis
semanas de uso de magnésio na fma de
treonato quando os pesquisadores
estenderam o período de experimentação
para 12 semanas houve ainda melhorias na
memória episódica ligada ao hipocampo
área essencial para formação de novas
memórias ao final do estudo os
resultados sugeriram que o magnésio
treonato pode reverter aspectos do
envelhecimento cerebral com melhorias na
função executiva equivalentes a um
rejuvenescimento cerebral de cerca de 9
anos impactando significativamente a
qualidade de vida especialmente em dosos
Fantástico não é e mais recentemente em
2023 um estudo confirmou que uma dose
diária de 550 MG de magnésio pode
acelerar o envelhecimento cerebral
especialmente pessoas na faixa dos 40
anos e ainda mais em mulheres na
pós-menopausa reduzindo sim o risco de
desenvolvimento de demência no futuro
agora compreendem Porque é tão
importante seja através da alimentação
ou de suplementos garantir uma
quantidade adequada de magnésio em nosso
corpo é
fundamental os
vos vi de alguém pode mudar também no
canal
[Música]
dovv Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
não esquece de dividir esse vídeo com
seus amigos e familiares você é fera